you
you just think you're so tough all right
I've seen this line before and we're
gonna reinforce d5 the plan here is to
trash-talk that's the plan the plan here
is to trash-talk as much as possible
against the computer okay I already feel
like I'm in trouble
let's induce some weaknesses you're
gonna play f3 no I love that I love that
why do I love that so much because I got
rid of my they're very important Bishop
if the bish if f3 was played I would
what was I gonna do
I was going to run home man I was gonna
run home let's castle so if pawn push no
we're not having that about here go with
it my knight wants to be on c6
ok the threat is takes takes and then
takes on c5 I don't like that
should I play this it weakens this
diagonal but maybe that's not too much
of an issue I think I like this let's go
with it huh all right I'm not afraid of
that I don't think Oh a closed position
hmm maybe d4 space gainer see if I play
d4 I think white could follow up and
maybe right away or eventually be 5 and
then there's Knight d2 and then the e4
square it could be occupied let's see
huh what is the plan here I don't want
to take because that I'm just opening it
up for my queen to get hit and just in
general the positions opening up could I
keep this tension and just throw a
question of the bishop if here there
probably capture takes maybe even
another capture I think I'd be okay with
that though h6 takes here takes takes
and then this I just lock it up I don't
think that that would go okay
we're not having this wolf interesting
can't do this I run into a fork huh
Knight here hmm
I think this move is gonna be played I
don't think I could stop it my night
I'll be kicked maybe you have to do this
this if the bishop moves then here then
there's Knight takes pawn
he's tactically vulnerable on that
square let me let me just go here Oh II
five isn't being played so I could get
this in but then you could be sure this
is the next pawn break I gotta close it
up though he's out of play this night on
b3 ah what piece could do better how
could I improve my position if I do this
I'm giving this square up this is gonna
be a great home for a night hmm this
Knight can't pivot on this square to
free up the f4 advance so I want to keep
him here maybe after the Knight moves
then I'll go Bishop d6 this Knight yeah
I feel like he could do something or
should be doing something different let
me try this kick him around oh okay so
this side of the board is closed Queen
here
I guess Queen here and then something
like this the Knights gonna move no he's
not moving I guess rook here at least
we're playing on just half the board
okay it's making dummy moves it's a
closed position so it doesn't know what
it wants to do yes keep making dummy
moves okay it's gonna eventually not not
make a dummy move though it's gonna
start making progress and when it does
it's gonna be painful
maybe Queen here so that when the knight
moves I do this if I could get an F 5 F
4 things are gonna be beautiful I think
let's try that I haven't covered oh I
love that move I really do
I love that move f4 is mine it's all
mine I have control over this position I
think I want the dark square Bishop Soph
the board and then throw my knight in to
have four how could I manage that how
can I make that work let's start with
this Queen back home
when in doubt run home with your queen
that's not true but it's being silly
what about bishop here what about h6 and
then bishop here ah let's try it
47 seconds bishop here right now it's
all coming together
Knight here better now let's get rid of
that Bishop let's see how it takes yes
of course you're giving great value to
your bishop that's what you do that's
what you do and now I'm going to improve
let the trash-talking begin I've got to
make sure
h4 isn't happening there we go ah there
you go keep your shuffling every day
this this uh this computer is shuffling
another bad joke my knight goes here and
if you take them oh there he goes let's
double up here it's gonna be painful
looking to bring the pain here come on
let's go here my queen doesn't like
having to defend like this take my
knight then the rook straps sometimes it
does stuff like that no not in this case
Queen trade
hang on see if it wants a draw oh you
want to draw alright I take a I could
get a draw but I'm thirsty for more I'm
thirsty for more I have control over
this position clean trade got it next
phase I'm in trouble
I gotta do this I should have taken the
draw
no I'm not in trouble let's back up I'm
kind of stuck though actually come to
think of it let me get some sneaky moves
in time gainers these are tied gainers
now hmm I'd see that what's so wrong
with it
hope on oh it's crumbling now oh man I'm
in trouble I'm in trouble now
too much fanciness man I lost control I
lost control man yeah this is gonna be
painful night check is nice
keep pushing right here let's bind up
huh oh it has a sneaky check that tricky
night oh what a bug what a bug not even
sure what that move does besides drop
upon I lost control
I should taken the job I should've taken
the drive this is hopeless now oh man
I'm down on time - in position let's go
not seen the last of me
you